de niña fui muy tímida
también retrospectiva creativa soñadora
pero recuerdo aquella sensación de
fragilidad de temor exponerme a un grupo
reducido de personas y agilidad las más
fuertes palpitaciones rubor
de niña
anduve en vueltas de oftalmólogos
ópticas políticas de especialidades
animales tuvo que andar por mi miopía
severa y tuve que adaptarme desde muy
temprana edad al uso de lentes de
contacto como también estar en contacto
con muchos niños con desafíos en el
desarrollo a los que veía conocía en
aquellas largas esperas de policlínicas
de especialidades
a mis 17 años estaba terminando el
bachillerato humanístico
estaba también terminando mis estudios
académicos de piano sabía que iba a ser
magisterio pero no tenía muy claro cómo
iba a seguir
había una inclinación entre lo artístico
y la educación pero no visualizaba del
todo mi futuro
un día estaba sentada
en el escalón del zaguán de mi casa y se
acerca una vecina que hacía muy poquito
está en san josé
que tenía una hijita de 23 años a la que
habían diagnosticado autismo
que ya estaba hace un año en terapia de
tipo 5 dinámica pero que ahora habían
contactado a un psiquiatra en buenos
aires
uno de los profesionales más admirados
por mí dentro de lo que es el abordaje a
personas con trastornos de espectro
autista el doctor ángel garcía coto
que iba a evaluarla y armarle un plan de
abordaje dentro de lo que es su programa
neurocognitivo
que necesitaban personas que se
capacitarán para ejecutar como
terapeutas de este programa la terapia
en el día a día en su domicilio
yo no tenía más que perder que aquel
susto enorme que me daba en exponerme a
situaciones de ese tipo y acepté el
desafío
y haber aceptado a ese desafío fue el
inicio de empezar a encontrar un sentido
para mi vida
a través de un camino en el que mis
potencialidades
qué tienen que ver con la flexibilidad y
la creatividad tenían un lugar para
andar
cada encuentro con florencia y luego con
los sucesivos cientos de chiquitos con
tea que fui conociendo y empezó a
convertirse en una aventura fascinante
de la que no pude desprenderme más
y que me fue enseñando que en esto si
bien hay muchas herramientas estrategias
tips que suelen funcionar en la mayoría
de los casos en realidad el centro de la
intervención tiene que ver con estar
completamente disponibles en aquel
momento en que tenemos a esa personita
enfrente y
con la flexibilidad creatividad y sobre
todo empatía al servicio de generar
un vínculo en el que el otro se sienta
comprendido protegido en confort
visto en sus potencialidades vanidad
este camino de transformación fue
haciendo que superará también mis
barreras personales y empecé a
encontrarme de pronto dando cursos de
capacitación charlas ponencias en
congresos porque lo que movía y mueve
los sitios de mencionar tiene que ver
con aquello en lo que me hace sentirme
útil para mi entorno y lo que me motiva
a lo que quiero compartir con los demás
ha ido transformándose también el
concepto de autismo en estos años
le llamamos ahora los trastornos de
espectro autista y se ha ido
transformando también el concepto de
discapacidad
tal como lo dice la sensación mundial de
la salud el concepto de discapacidad se
desprende de la interacción entre la
persona con desafíos en el desarrollo y
las barreras que encuentra en su entorno
trabajar en discapacidad es esto
trabajar en derribar barreras
cuando uno va a armar un plan de
abordaje
cuando va a plantearse objetivos piensa
trata de visualizar la mejor
vida posible para esa persona cuál sería
la forma en que accedería la mejor
calidad de vida
y para eso uno tiene modelos los cuales
basarse para suponer una vida de buena
calidad a mí me gusta pensar en modelos
como luis suárez tu entrada china
zorrilla maria noel riccetto maria jose
sigue personas que se han permitido la
felicidad de hacer todos los días lo que
más les gusta si uno piensa en ellos
lo primero que queda expuesto son sus
talentos
puedo también dar ejemplos de personas
con desafíos en el desarrollo que han
logrado de esta felicidad
por ejemplo temple grandín es una mujer
con autismo
qué es esto logar zoóloga profesora de
comportamiento animal escritos libros e
insignias en torno a lo que es el
pensamiento animal en todo el mundo y es
además de las primeras personas
que ha podido dar su testimonio de lo
que es vivir con autismo y para esto
probablemente ha tenido que ir superando
muchas de sus barreras personales pero
lo que la mueve es aquello que a ella
la hace sentirse en su potencialidad en
su autenticidad
iván música nació sin extremidades
sigue viviendo sin extremidades y sin
embargo es un orador motivacional
influyente en todo el mundo
jesús vidal
es actor nació con ceguera total en un
ojo y miopía patológica de un 90% en el
otro
sin embargo en el 2019 ganó el premio
goya a mejor actor revelación por la
película campeones
stephen hawking quien no lo conoce los
últimos años necesitan de un aparato
generador de la voz para poder exponer
sus pensamientos sin embargo fue de los
principales impulsores del debate
científico de los últimos años
y ejemplos de personas públicas para que
podamos tener referentes comunes pero no
es necesario llegar al claro público yo
creo que lo necesario es llegar
en la potencia blanca
hay un par de puntos más en común en
estas personas
todos ellos tuvieron familias o entornos
familiares cercanos que los ayudarán a
sostener la motivación día a día para
que su vida se trazará en torno a estas
actividades centradas en sus
potencialidades
hay una frase que dijo jesús vidal
cuando fue a recibir su premio goya que
se le dedicó a sus padres que a mí me
gusta mucho les dijo
a mí me gustaría tener un hijo como yo
porque tuve unos padres como ustedes
y yo creo que ahí está el centro de lo
que tenemos que aprender
los padres
apuntar a nuestros hijos en sus
potencialidades poder verlos en aquello
en lo que son fuertes y auténticos en
sus motivaciones naturales
y poder motivarlos a que sigan
construyendo su vida por ese camino y no
tanto visualizar los desafíos porque
probablemente los desafíos se van a ir
resolviendo en la medida que el pulso
vital de cada uno se pueda ir
fortaleciendo en torno a aquellas
actividades centradas en las
potencialidades
y un tercer punto en común es que todas
estas personas
siente por esas actividades centradas en
sus potencialidades que están cumpliendo
una función en su entorno o sea han
encontrado un sentido para su vida
puedo quizás
pensar que cualquier desafío
si es mirado de esa manera o sea
si es mirado en su potencialidad
si somos capaces de ponerle motivación y
si somos capaces de encontrarle un
sentido se va a convertir y va a generar
espirales evolutivas de transformación
positiva
voy a compartir un par de ejemplos como
para visualizar cómo podría ser
plantear algunos objetivos a corto plazo
teniendo en cuenta estos tres puntos y
objetivos a largo plazo teniendo en
cuenta estos tres puntos supongamos que
llega a nuestra consulta un chiquito de
temprana edad
el cual lo que veo es que se balancea
no observo contacto ocular en el momento
no observo lenguaje pero observo el
balanceo entonces puedes ubicarme köhler
va a denunciar me con él quizá hacer el
piso quizás en una hamaca paraguay y
estoy un ratito balanceando mi con él y
cuando lo siento
lo ayudó a que se detenga quizás al
principio no le guste mucho pero un
poquito me coloco en su horizonte y
cuando se cruzan las miradas sonrío y
volvemos a balancear nos
un ratito pero una vez más
vuelvo a esperar el contacto ocular con
la sonrisa la dispara de nuevo nos
volvemos a balancear y así algunas veces
hasta que empiezo a percibir que está
entendiendo esto de que la estoy
observando en su potencialidad que es
balancearse te estoy motivando a que la
siga haciendo
estoy encontrando y le está encontrando
un sentido de sí mismo que él dispara
esto de volver a balanceando juntos
un ejemplo de cómo podríamos ir trazando
objetivos a largo plazo
llega la consulta
muy chiquito que tengo la familia no se
comunica a través del lenguaje verbal le
resulta muy difícil estar en entornos
muy bulliciosos
está haciendo difícil la integración
escolar
pero que es muy bueno
en su oído musical aprende canciones de
memoria las canta solitos tiene un
micrófono en su casa y puede estar horas
cantando y imitan muy bien diferentes
cantantes entonces yo quizás lo que me
tengo que plantear es desde el arranque
en la sesión tener un micrófono e ir
pensando el abordaje desde allí bueno
como voy a hacer a través de canciones
para ir trabajando turnos conversaciones
cómo voy a hacer para que después pueda
compartir esa actividad con otros padres
cómo voy a intervenir para que la
escuela lo pueda también introducir en
esta actividad para compartir espacios
sociales
quizás en los recreos quizás en clase
quizás más adelante pueda incluirlo
alguna actividad de cierre de la
institución en alguna tira de barrial y
puedo ir de a poquito imaginando hasta
un futuro laboral en torno a su
potencialidad
debería dar muchos ejemplos para poder
abarcar un aspecto más amplio
pero quiero centrarme también en una
realidad
muy poderosa
que quizás no es la más sencilla de
asimilar pero que si la omitiera estaría
recortando una parte
d
la realidad que atestigua en estos 24 25
años de trabajo
qué
es demasiado importante
y poder compartirla y no ocultaba y es
que hay algunas personas
con trastornos de espectro autista
o con desafíos en el desarrollo o
algunas personas
que por ahí no van a alcanzar demasiados
logros
cuantificables
más allá de todas las abordajes que sea
debido a la profundidad de sus desafíos
pero
que su fortaleza la motivación y sobre
todo el sentido
que cumplen en su entorno
es de tan alto y amplio
alcance impacto
que generan transformaciones
o espirales evolutivas de transformación
en sus entornos
que son de las más trascendentes que he
observado y que por eso
puedo compararnos con la luz
por qué
le permiten a nuestros ojos ver
de verdad
ver